let's talk about the worst
fighting between israelis and
palestinians in a long time
[Applause]
the gaza strip is a war zone
battered by days of israeli air attacks
and artillery
children have been killed homes have
been pulverized
tens of thousands of people left with
nowhere to go
israeli civilians have been killed too
but far fewer than the palestinians
and in neighborhoods across israel and
the occupied west bank
people have turned on each other but
this bloodshed
goes back a long time what's being
referred to as an escalation violence
didn't start with gaza so where did it
start
what is this fight all about and how
does it end
before we get into it let's take a
moment to get a sense
of the scale of the human cost at the
time we recorded this
nearly 200 palestinians including more
than 50
children had been killed by israeli
attacks on gaza
more than a thousand palestinians
wounded at least 10 people in israel
including two children have been killed
by rockets fired from gaza
and more than 250 wounded and in the
occupied west bank including east
jerusalem
at least 19 palestinians have been
killed and thousands injured by israeli
security forces
civilians vulnerable people are the most
afflicted at the moment
though it might look on on tv sometimes
as as computer games
this is computer games with real people
which pay with death and
injuries and devastation
so how did we get here well we're going
to focus on what happened
when and where over the last few weeks
here is gaza it's where the worst
violence has happened
but we'll come back to that in a bit
gaza is part of the occupied palestinian
territories
that also include east jerusalem and the
west bank
they're called occupied because israel
took them by force after the six day war
in 1967.
now let's look at occupied east
jerusalem the old city is there
and includes sites considered holy by
jews muslims and christians
and this is the damascus gate it's one
of the entry points into the old city
it's also where things started heating
up in april
at the beginning of ramadan israeli
forces put up fences there
they said it was to prevent crowding but
palestinians felt they were being kept
out deliberately
another example of israel making them
feel like the city isn't theirs
eventually the fences were removed but
there were several nights of fighting
between
unarmed protesters and israeli forces
not far from the damascus gate and also
in occupied east jerusalem
is the neighborhood of sheikh
there have been a series of court cases
there since the 1970s
over who owns certain homes in may an
israeli court said that several
palestinian families should be forced
out
ruling in favor of an association of
israeli settlers
they represent probably some of the most
radical extreme
settlers they at the end of the day
believe it's
it all belongs to them so people came
out to protest
[Applause]
[Music]
israeli security forces cracked down
while some settlers provoked
palestinians you
are stealing my house and if i don't
steal it someone else is gonna steal it
the case is now with the israeli supreme
court but the justices have postponed
their hearing
now remember is an occupied territory in
east jerusalem
an international law not israeli law is
supposed to apply
so for palestinians what the settlers
and israeli courts are doing
is plain theft the u.n says it may even
be a war crime
the evictions if ordered and implemented
would violate
israel's obligations under international
law
but the israeli government sees it very
differently and argues that israel
has the authority to do what it wants in
jerusalem
is
and this is why became such a focus of
palestinian anger
because jerusalem is not israel's
capital according to the vast majority
of the international community
how the city is ultimately shared
between israel and a future palestinian
state
still has to be negotiated but while
this doesn't happen
israel is changing things on the ground
and palestinians feel that what's going
on in shakhtar
is part of a much larger pattern of
annexation and dispossession
this has happened across palestine where
israel
allows itself to appropriate land
and houses on a really
false legal pretext so let's bring up
our map again
israeli forces were cracking down on
protesters in
sheikh jarrah for several days then on
may 7th
in the old city tens of thousands of men
women and children were at the final
friday prayers of ramadan
at the al-aqsa mosque one of the holiest
sites in islam
afterwards there were protests in the
old city but israeli forces raided the
mosque's compound
they threw stun grenades and fired
rubber-coated steel bullets at
palestinians
some of whom were throwing stones and it
spiraled from there
by the following monday there was tear
gas inside the mosque itself
the sea it laid siege to was incredibly
emotional for a lot of people around the
world
this is where gaza comes back in it's a
small strip of land where nearly 2
million palestinians are
crammed in they can't get out easily
because for the last 14 years
israel has imposed a land air and sea
blockade
and gaza is run by hamas a palestinian
group that israel and the u.s consider
terrorists now after all the violence in
east jerusalem
the top commander of hamas warned israel
that it had until 6 pm that monday
to withdraw its security forces from the
al-aqsa mosque compound
and jerusalem's sheikshana neighborhood
when the deadline passed
hamas fired rockets into central israel
and israel's military attacked
they destroyed this building after
warning people inside to leave
then hamas responded again this is a
wave after wave
of attacks coming out of gaza now these
rockets
are heading in the direction of tel aviv
from there it just got worse
relentless air attacks by the israelis
and thousands of rockets launched by
hamas
most of those rockets were shot down by
israel's iron dome defense system
but in gaza there's nothing like that
reports continue of families
women children and infants killed in
their homes by
airspikes one israeli attack hit a
refugee camp
killing two women and eight children
from the same family
several buildings were targeted
including one that housed the offices of
international
media like the associated press and al
jazeera
al jazeera's office is out there we are
another strike on that tower
and the terror has come down
the impact will be to reduce the flow of
information coming from gaza
israel says it's only targeting fighters
and military assets
and it accuses hamas of hiding them
among civilians
and in residential buildings but here's
the thing about gaza
when you bomb a densely populated area
such as gaza there are going to be
civilian casualties no matter what with
all this going on in gaza
over in israel and the occupied west
bank we've been seeing something we
rarely see
thousands of palestinian citizens of
israel taking to the streets and towns
villages
and what are known as mixed cities to
assert their identity and rights
but it has also seemed to trigger some
palestinian israelis and jewish israelis
to start attacking each other there are
many horrible videos posted online
of arabs being beaten up in the street
businesses smashed in
and vehicles and a synagogue set on fire
it's the worst between communities
living alongside each other
in decades so how does this all end
well a ceasefire for gaza is the first
essential step and the un
egypt and qatar have all been involved
in international mediation efforts to
make that happen
we also urge them to allow us as a
humanitarian to
to move and to provide our emergency
response a ceasefire is only the
beginning
because events over the last few weeks
are set against a backdrop of
decades in which the israeli government
has denied palestinians their basic
rights
it's a system that human rights watch
and others have described as apartheid
they are not equal or full citizens
indeed they're incredibly marginalized
and discriminated against the us as
israel's most important ally
has a special role to play in this
people are looking to president joe
biden to see whether he'll say or do
things differently from previous
administrations
he hasn't so far my expectation and hope
is that
this will be uh closing down sooner than
later
but israel has a right to defend itself
when you have thousands of rockets
flying into
your territory but we've been here
before
and to avoid being here again something
has to change
the only way that this will end is with
full decolonization
palestinian liberation the divide is not
necessarily right now between
jews and arabs between those who believe
that can be
a coexistence reconciliation that the
two people can live in peace in the same
and
respecting each other and those who
don't think like this
right now that idea of peaceful
coexistence
may seem impossibly far off but the
answer
can't be to just keep going like this
[Music]
hopefully that was a useful starting
point but obviously there is so much
more context to this story on
aljazeera.com we've got data
interactives
plenty of analysis and a live blog with
all the latest
i'll see you next week
you